in 2020 nasa celebrated 20 years of
astronauts continuously inhabiting the
international space station
the iss is no doubt an engineering
marvel and is arguably the most
significant and extensive space project
thus far
not only is the iss an engineering
masterpiece but the iss serves as a
symbol of international cooperation
and collaboration clocking in over two
decades though
the iss is heading into the latter half
of its life
so how does nasa plan to phase out the
iss and what comes
next taking a look at the state of the
iss today
it's not bad by any means a significant
portion of the station's core structures
were manufactured way back in the 1990s
but all of the station's components were
built to last decades
moreover we have already seen several
space hardware last much longer
for instance the hubble space telescope
has been in space for over 30 years at
this point
similarly warrior 1 and 2 are still
transmitting information to earth
and those were launched in 1977 with
that being said though
space is a rather harsh environment and
radiation is a serious concern
just last year a russian cosmonaut fixed
a small air leak in one of the space
station's modules
so the space station does suffer from
minor damage here and there
but with the close attention nasa has
been giving it maintaining the iss for
another few decades wouldn't be too
difficult for nasa
congress just extended the lifetime of
the iss from 2024
to 2030 so we have at least another 10
years for sure
the real problem with the iss was never
the longevity of its hardware though
the primary reasons that nasa is looking
to phase out the iss is because of cost
time and new technology the iss is
estimated to have cost a total of 100
billion dollars just to build
and an additional three to four billion
dollars every year to maintain
given that nasa's budget is about 25
billion dollars per year
14 of the entire revenue that nasa
receives goes directly towards
maintaining the iss
at the same time the hardware and
testing equipment onboard the iss is
starting to get outdated
nasa has confirmed that there is still a
lot for them to learn just about low
earth orbit
but a lot of the tests they want to
conduct can be performed more
efficiently
and more accurately by newer hardware
and at one point
continuously sending new hardware to the
iss simply doesn't make sense
nasa isn't just going to disassemble the
iss and call it a day though
nasa has already invested tens of
billions into the iss
and they're planning on recuperating at
least some of this in 2019
nasa announced that they were going to
start renting out the international
space station
this includes a variety of commercial
activities such as tourism to the iss
filming in the iss manufacturing iss and
even conducting your own experiments
on the iss this is honestly a super cool
idea in my opinion
nasa has already completed a lot of what
they wanted to do on the iss
and now they're looking to make some
money off of it something that's
baffling to me though
is the cost i don't know why but for
some reason
the government is insistent upon
investing ludicrous amounts and then
charging pennies whether it be the
subway the postal service
or now the international space station
the government loves to overpay
and then under charge i understand that
these are public services
and aren't meant to turn a profit but i
think it would make a lot of sense to at
least to break even
that way they're not burning billions
every year just keeping the service
afloat
and they can invest the money elsewhere
but
that's just what i think anyways nasa
plans to charge 35 000
per day per crew and a crew can be up to
as many people as you can fit onto a
single flight
so if you were just in the starship
filled with 100 passengers
it would only cost each member 350 per
day
there is a catch though only four
passengers can be in the station at any
time
so if you want to maximize your time
when visiting the iss
ideally you would only travel with three
other members that's still only eight
thousand seven hundred and fifty dollars
per day per person to stay
on the international space station
ironically a stay at the brazil arab
could end up costing you
more nasa is planning on initially
offering two commercial rent windows
every year
lasting up to 30 days each at that rate
nasa could pull in about 2.1 million
annually if nasa decides sex and the
service to be year-round
that could pull in up to 12.775 million
dollars
annually to put that in perspective
12.775 million dollars would be enough
to run the iss for a whopping
one and a half days nasa claims that
they're offering the service as cheap as
possible
to excite as many commercial customers
as possible
here's the thing though getting to the
iss itself costs tens of millions
so i don't think a more expensive rent
price would really deter customers
but anyways that's essentially nasa's
plan long term
they have some contracts with the
company called axiom space who is
manufacturing a couple of tourist
modules that they plan to attach to the
iss
nasa is hoping to connect these new
modules to the iss by the end of 2021
and get commercial customers in as soon
as possible but
what happens after the iss has had its
time as a commercial hotspot
also what happens to the other countries
invested in the iss
well russia has already announced their
plans to leave the iss
their contract with the us and the other
countries involved in the iss
expires in 2024 and as of right now
they don't plan on extending this
contract this is not necessarily out of
hostility or anything like that
space technology has significantly
improved since the iss was planned
and you no longer need all of the space
superpowers to work together to create a
space station
as a result russia is looking to build
their own space station by 2023
after their iss contract expires russia
is planning on disconnecting their
portion of the iss
and using the module in their new space
station this was announced in 2015
though
so maybe planes have changed since then
it's very possible that russia decides
to just leave their portion of the iss
connected
as it is old hardware and this would be
easy way to showcase unity
but either way their main focus will no
doubt lie on their own national space
station program
considering this after the 2024 contract
expires
all countries involved in the iss will
likely have the same options
they can either stay connected and
support the commercial activity on the
iss
or they can disconnect their portions of
the iss and do whatever they want with
it
given that congress extended the
lifespan of the iss to 2030
we can be sure that there will be at
least some resemblance of the iss till
2030.
if we simply take a look at how long the
iss can last i suspect 2050 is around
the upper echelon of how far the iss can
be pushed
anything longer than that simply
wouldn't make sense
thus the iss will likely get defunded
anywhere between 2030
and 2050. it really just depends on the
economic situation and commercial
interest at the time
if the cost to maintain the iss
significantly declines and there's a lot
of commercial interest
it's very possible that congress ends up
extending the iss to 2040
and maybe even 2050. if the iss
continues to cost billions every year
though
it's likely that nasa would prefer to
spend that money elsewhere after 2030.
whenever the time comes though it's
definitely going to be a very
bittersweet moment
nasa can't just leave the iss in space
as it's quite a big object
if it ends up deorbiting by itself it
could endanger people on the ground
thus nasa has to make sure that it is
deorbited safely
they've been working on this plan since
the start of the program so this
shouldn't be a problem
the deorbit plan involves a controlled
re-entry into the atmosphere during
which the iss will burn up
and all the debris will land in the
ocean i'm sure that nasa
and other space agencies will save
certain parts of the iss and bring it
back to the earth to place it in a
museum or something like that
but unfortunately a large portion of the
iss will end up as debris
in the ocean looking forward though we
do have new space stations to look
forward to
as i mentioned before russia is working
on their own space station
and this is the same case with china as
well
so the us won't be able to form
partnerships with these two countries
for a new station
in the imminent future it is possible
that nasa builds a new space station in
conjunction with europe
japan canada and maybe even india but
this
is unlikely the truth is the iss was
extremely expensive to build
and maintain it and i don't think nasa
nor these other countries are looking to
go down this path
again nasa has recently really embraced
the private space industry
and it's very likely that they do the
same thing when it comes to the next
space station
i suspect that the next space station
from the us will be accomplished by
private companies getting together
as opposed to countries getting together
by the 2030s
starship development should be done and
hopefully blue origin will have
completed new glen development
as well if elon musk and jeff bezos
joined forces
it would be a nice throwback to when
russia and the u.s join forces
in such a scenario spacex and blue
origin would take care of all the
launches
meanwhile companies like boeing and
action would design and manufacture
modules to be connected
in space and finally nasa would guide
approve and finance the entire project
nasa wouldn't be the only one financing
space stations though
it's likely that we'll also see several
massive hotel and tourism companies
enter the space as well
they'll be looking to build space hotels
and resorts and basically any other
tourist attraction they can
and unlike nasa they'll be sure to
charge as much as they can get away with
not going to lie though a space hotel
seems pretty cool and i'd be willing to
pick quite a bit
as long as it's safe and reliable in the
end
the iss is entering the last stages of
its life nasa
and other space agencies have already
been experimenting on the space station
for two decades
and they're about ready to move on so
they're opening up the space station to
commercial customers for movie
production
research and tourism once this has gone
on for a while
nasa is looking to deal with the space
station probably somewhere in the 2030s
finally nasa will switch to funding
private space stations
and that's what nasa plans to phase out
the iss
are you guys excited about private space
stations and space hotels
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys think that the iss will
always have its place
in history and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari i'll see you
guys on the next one